u.s military forces have launched a
drone strike hitting a car they say was
carrying suicide bombers planning to
attack kabul airport an airport bombing
on thursday killed scores of civilians
and 13 u.s personnel
video showed smoke billowing from a home
near kabul airport on sunday afternoon
there are reports four children are
among six civilians killed
we have two correspondents covering the
developing story in a moment we'll go to
rob reynolds with the latest from
washington dc
but first let's start with charles
stratford he's live for us in
afghanistan's capital kabul so charles
we've had a series of reports of attacks
is it clear on the ground level who's
hit who
it is far from clear still sammy a good
three hours or so
since the reports of these attacks came
through indeed since
a statement was released by centcom u.s
military command
what we are hearing certainly from
people that we've spoken to in that area
and this is an area that is beyond the
primitive fence north of the airport
they're saying what they described as a
rocket attack
hit a home
and there have been civilian casualties
but all evidence is suggesting
that uh the two attacks
certainly the the what is reported as a
rocket attack and this reported um
drone strike against what uh the u.s
military was saying was a car full of
suicide bombers may well be the same
strike it's
very unusual so far that we've heard
nothing from the taliban they were very
swift in actually condemning a drone
strike that uh the us military launched
against two what they described as high
priority isil members um around about 24
hours ago now they condemned it on the
basis of
being unhappy with what they said was
their lack of consultation with the
americas they said that the americans
didn't actually tell them that they were
going to launch this strike so we've
heard nothing
yet about this latest strike from the
taliban but of course
this all comes at a time of increasing
tension as this evacuation
operation winds down it's been very
quiet certainly the last i'd say five or
six hours we've heard
no planes taking off or landing at the
airport certainly from here
and we've heard obviously hundreds of
aircraft
in and around the airport overhead in
recent days we understand
that the
the process was still going on this
morning because we spoke to a group of
people on a bus who told us that they
had all the
requisite documents the either a visa or
a passport or some sort of
official invitation and they've been had
their papers processed and been told to
head to the airport on this bus and then
had been turned away
we know the taliban security has uh been
stepped up
in recent days because of this threat
level of terror attacks and certainly in
the wake of those horrific
that horrific attack on thursday that
killed at least 110 people including
13 u.s servicemen
so
the situation is unclear about what
exactly has happened this evening but
the situation we do know is very tense
and it's unclear as to whether the
evacuations are indeed over
yet
or whether there are still people that
will get into the airport and get on to
flights
all right that was charles stratford
from kabul let's continue this now
u.s president joe biden has been taking
part in a ceremony to bring home the
bodies of service personnel killed in
kabul he's received the bodies of 13
people they were among the victims
killed by suicide bombers at the airport
on thursday isil k claimed
responsibility the u.s targeted the
group with drone strikes in nangarhar
province
and the secretary of state anthony
blinken has addressed the media he
maintains the us will continue to have
the ability to attack targets in
afghanistan even without soldiers on the
ground
we have the capacity
around the world including in
afghanistan
to
take uh to find and to take strikes
against terrorists who uh who want to do
us harm and as you know in uh country
after country including places like uh
like yemen uh like somalia uh large
parts of syria libya places where we
don't have boots on the ground on any
kind of
ongoing basis
we have the capacity to go after people
who are trying to do us harm we'll
retain that capacity in afghanistan
let's bring in now rob reynolds he's
standing by live for us in washington dc
and rob so what are officials saying
about the result of that u.s drone
strike in afghanistan
well in a statement that charlie
referred to from the u.s central command
the
military says that they successfully
carried out a drone strike against a
vehicle
they said that they
observed secondary explosions after
hitting the vehicle
which they
said
indicated that it had
on board a large amount of bomb or
explosive material
so
they are saying that this was an isil k
operation that they disrupted uh they uh
said in a uh in in their statement that
there was no indication of civilian
casualties so how that squares with what
uh charlie and others are seeing on the
ground with reports of civilian
casualties is not known but the u.s
military says it is going to continue uh
to do uh this sort of post-operation
assessment of what's going on there and
uh very interesting sami uh uh that's
the sound bite from the u.s secretary of
state anthony blinken that he played a
moment ago indicating that this sort of
thing this uh
air strikes drone strikes over the
horizon as they're called
attacks
will continue in afghanistan so the
actual
shooting war the fighting war that's
that has been going on for two decades
may be
drawing to a conclusion but the uh the
the actual the the the fighting and the
the warfare the acts of war may be
continuing for some time to come how
long who knows
and rob is an understanding coming
together for
evacuations of americans perhaps others
after august the 31st
yes uh well at least the u.s national
security adviser jake sullivan
said today and there was a release of a
statement from the state department as
well saying that 97 countries had banded
together with the united states to
demand that the
afghan
taliban honor commitments
to allow safe passage for foreign
nationals
and
afghans who possess
the necessary transfer papers to
relocate to
third countries and allow them safe
passage out of the country so of course
if the airport is closing down with the
departure of u.s troops uh and uncertain
how how many flights will go in and out
or who will actually control that
airstrip that leaves the ground routes
outside of afghanistan as a possible
exit plan for these people there are
about 250
u.s citizens still remaining in the
country and of course many thousands of
afghans associated with the nato effort
who would also like to leave
all right we'll leave you there thanks
so much rob reynolds